hablamos de la situación de la violencia
en mexico tres periodistas fueron
asesinados en ese país durante lo
corrido 2022 además se reportan
agresiones y asesinatos contra
integrantes de la comunidad lgtb y la
última víctima mortal fue la periodista
lourdes maldonado en tijuana aunque la
comunicadora tenía asignado un esquema
de seguridad su presencia no era
permanente algo que aprovecharon los
perpetradores de este crimen para
dispararle cuando llegaba a su
residencia estos casos evidencian el
difícil panorama de seguridad que se
registra en ese país por ello quiero
saludar entonces a nuestra segunda
invitada del día ella es ana elena
contreras fundadora de las aquelarre
feminista asesora en el congreso local
de la ciudad de mexico grasas gracias
ana elena por estar con nosotros aquí en
directo américa de france 24 me preguntó
que explica este recrudecimiento de la
violencia en méxico contra los
periodistas y también miembros de la
comunidad lgtb
hola que tal buenos dias
bueno no es que haya propiamente un
reconocimiento no ha podido haber una
desaceleración no el panorama en general
para las mujeres que vivimos en méxico
como en otros países de américa latina y
alrededor del mundo o sigue siendo ese
no
siempre estamos quienes quienes están
alzando la voz y exponiendo determinadas
situaciones pues están en el ojo de la
mira
la violencia contra mujeres y activistas
periodistas es algo que viene dándose
desde pues desde hace mucho tiempo no no
se ha podido controlar porque también es
un tema que tiene que ver con prácticas
patriarcales no que están atravesando
pues toda la situación en el país que
pasa exactamente con las mujeres y las
miembros de la comunidad lgtb que tan
difícil es ser miembro de esta comunidad
de ser una persona trans o una persona
homosexual
bueno
me refiero en este caso a
específicamente al caso del feminicidio
de dos políticas
lesbianas no este que recientemente
fueron también asesinadas no con una
saña total y ahí retomó nuevamente el
tema del patriarcado que yo sé que puede
sonar de pronto mucho cáncer pero que
está colocado ahí esta violencia que se
vive o este este asesinato es de doble
feminicidio de estas chicas pues lo que
demuestra en exceso no que hay una
extraña patriarcal izada una violencia
una molestia de hacia las mujeres en
cuanto salen de lo que es el rol de lo
que debería de ser no entonces la
molestia en este caso generó ese género
debido a sus preferencias sexuales de
ser dos mujeres no viviendo una vida
lesbiana y que rompe por completo el
deber ser de lo que dice el patriarcado
y la sociedad que deberíamos de ser las
mujeres
también hablamos de los feminicidios
cómo se ha recrudecido estos
feminicidios a lo largo lo que va de año
este 2022 y bueno digamos teniendo en
cuenta las cifras del año 2021 a lo
mejor estas cifras de este año podrían
disminuir o lamentablemente aumentar
como es el panorama para este año
respecto a eso en méxico
en materia de feminicidios
lamentablemente tenemos una alza desde
el 2016 se reportaba que teníamos 7
mujeres y niñas asesinadas diariamente y
estamos en 2020 2 con 11 mujeres al día
no es algo que no mientras las mujeres y
las feministas vamos ganando terreno en
las actividades en los pronunciamientos
pues también hay una contra respuesta no
a la violencia machista que se ejerce
como castigo también en contra de
nosotros y este es un fenómeno que
seguramente cualquier sociólogo puede
darle como competen a la perspectiva de
género puede dar como una respuesta muy
clara no
y la violencia ejercida contra las
mujeres actualmente atiende también a un
llamado o una reacción patriarcal para
decir que no tenemos que estar saliendo
de lo que tiene que ser no las mujeres
se nos quieren los ámbitos privados
calladas sin hacer ruido y obedeciendo
cuando esto no sucede porque estamos
ganando terreno porque estamos
posicionando nos estamos avanzando en
materia también de los derechos de las
mujeres es cuando hay una una respuesta
extrema de violencia
como trabajan ustedes desde el congreso
local de mexico para que esto pare para
ofrecerle también me imagino apoyo y
ayuda a estas víctimas de la violencia
no solamente pues si hablamos hablamos
de las mujeres pero a lo mejor no sé si
también apoyan a otro tipo a cualquier
persona digamos que sufra violencia
claro el tema de la violencia en general
y si se tiene que ver con lupa no se
está trabajando a través de la creación
y revisión de políticas públicas cuando
yo te puedo hablar únicamente del tema
de las mujeres porque es el tema que yo
manejo no este hay un cuidado especial
en materia de violencia de género se
está haciendo un seguimiento como muy
puntual en relación a la alerta de
violencia de género que por ejemplo en
la ciudad de mexico se está dando este
se están haciendo revisión de protocolos
creación de unidades especiales donde se
le puedan dar atención a este tipo de
violencia por ejemplo tenemos en ciudad
de méxico
una fiscalía especializada en materia de
violencia de género que tiende a los
feminicidios este esto es algo que se
tiene y que se está perfeccionando
tenemos una pizca la que además este
desde su formación es
claramente feminista y que da la
atención con esta perspectiva todo su
equipo está encaminado a darle respuesta
con perspectiva de género digamos eso en
la ciudad de méxico pero qué pasa en las
ciudades fronterizas donde esta
violencia contra las mujeres la
violencia de género lamentablemente es
más fuerte y es más común que pase en
estas ciudades fronterizas como trabaja
el gobierno como trabajan también
ustedes desde la centralización desde la
ciudad de méxico para ayudar a estas
víctimas y para tratar de que este tipo
de de bit de víctimas y de feminicidios
no sigan aumentando
bueno el trabajo de sociedad civil es
sin duda clave para poder darle solución
al tema de los derechos humanos de las
mujeres no en materia de temas
fronterizos ahí el trabajo va muy de la
mano con organizaciones internacionales
que atienden este fenómeno no solamente
de violencia sino que también pues de
migración no méxico es un país que es un
país de paso y que tiene como algunas
otras características más especializadas
en materia de inmigración y de la
violencia que se sufre a través de este
fenómeno y que se atiende pues entre de
manera colaborativa entre el gobierno y
organizaciones como la onu por ejemplo o
organizaciones de locales más pequeñas
que atienden también estos fenómenos
migratorios
ana elena ya para finalizar qué
recomendación le da a estas personas que
sufren de violencia de género digamos a
las mujeres por supuesto
muy importante seguir levantando la voz
en plena pandemia se hizo un
recrudecimiento muy fuerte lo que fue la
violencia y contra mujeres y niñas y
pues también hubo una respuesta de los
grupos y de los movimientos feministas y
se tuvieron avances sustanciales muy
importantes en materia de los derechos
de mujeres y niñas entonces la respuesta
siempre será levantar la voz la
organización para poder también hacer
una exigencia puntual el gobierno no
esté para que siempre tenga que estar
avanzando esta agenda y no se quede
estancada ante pues la respuesta que
desde la violencia que en general va
siempre en aumento no es una de las
características especiales de la
violencia entonces la recomendación es
siempre levantar la voz incluso cuando
no se tengan en apariencia una respuesta
positiva siempre será la respuesta de
levantar la voz y poderse organizar con
diferentes grupos feministas y
organizaciones que atienden temas de
derechos humanos de las mujeres